زين العابدين ما التطور المهم الذي حدث في
معبر رفح اليوم تطور غير مسبوق منذ بدايه
هذه المعركه معركه طوفان الاقصى في السابع
من اكتوبر اول مره يعبر مصابون من الجانب
الفلسطيني الى الجانب المصري لتلقي العلاج
اول مره يسمح لحمله الجوازات الاجنبيه
والجنسيات المزدوجه بالمرور ايضا اكثر من
66 جريحا وذويهم عبروا الى الجانب المصري
وحوالي 300 او اكثر من حمله الجوازات
الاجنبيه عبروا الى مصر ايضا من ضمنهم
مصريون كثيرون فلسطينيون من قطاع غزه
يحملون ايضا الجنسيه المصريه هذا تطور لم
يحدث منذ بدايه هذهه الحرب وهو طبعا ياتي
ضمن اليه يبدو انه متفق عليها بين قطر
ومصر واسرائيل والولايات المتحده لتسهيل
عبور الحالات الانسانيه وال حمله الجوازات
الاجنبيه من غزه الى الجهه الاخرى لكن
اللافت ايضا هو الذين يريدون ان يعبروا من
الجهه الاخرى الى قطاع غزه هؤلاء هم
الفلسطينيون
الذين اصبحوا عالقين في مطارات عده دول
منها مطار العريش في مصر وهؤلاء يريدون
العوده وهذا كان محل استغراب ان هنالك
فلسطينيين يريدون ان يعودوا الى غزه في ظل
هذا القصف الشديد والاوضاع
التي ترقى في راي كثير من المنظمات
وال الخبراء في مجال القانون الدولي وحقوق
الانسان الى اباده جماعيه وتطهير عرقي لكن
هنالك الفلسطينيون الذين يريدون العوده
الى ديارهم في قطاع غزه هنالك تطورات ايضا
سياسيه لافته تصاحب هذا التطور اليوم وهو
سحب الاردن استدعاء سفيرها من اسرائيل
وهذه اول دوله عربيه واسلاميه لها علاقات
مع اسرائيل تستدعي السفير وياتي طبعا تاتي
هذه الخطوه بعد
خطوات متقدمه في امريكا اللاتينيه من
بوليفيا التي قطعت العلاقات من تشيلي
وكولومبيا التي ايضا استدعت سفرائها تاتي
ايضا في ظل خطوات عربيه من دول ليست لها
علاقات مع اسرائيل كسلطان عمان التي الغت
اتفاقيه مرور الطائرات الاسرائيليه من
الاجواء
العمانيه وربما الايام المقبله تكون حبله
بت تطورات مماثله لكن ايضا من التطورات
السياسيه اللافته ما قاله اسماعيل نيه
رئيس المكتب السياسي لحركه حماس ان حماس
عرضت في الواقع خطه شامله تشمل تبادل
الاسرى تشمل البحث عن مسار للسلام لاقامه
دوله فلسطينيه وارساء حق تقرير المصير
للشعب الفلسطيني وايضا انهاء طبعا ما وصفه
بالعدوان الاسرائيلي المستمر على قطاع غزه